[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Alan sake on
really excited to be sitting down with
Lance Victor more talking about fashion
design that's the name of the game man
thank you for coming on to the show
ledger I'm really excited yeah there's
so much to talk about this is a very
artistic exhibit that you have here and
the created show just for you yes and
it's super avant-garde and it's also
very it's very interesting because it's
very different it's very it has an edge
to it it's like there's yeah there I
mean there's there's absolutely a big
part of futurism and what I do I've
always been a fan of sci-fi which it
probably is relatively so self-evident
but when I say futurism I don't
necessarily just mean it has to look
futuristic I mean that product itself
should look towards the future in the
way that it's not just produced but what
its content is why it's produced there's
using sustainable methods in the way
that you do as much as I can I mean
obviously there are things in it that I
have no control over and I'm not at a
point in where I produce things yet
where I can have control over that but
when I'm able to I try and make sure
that pieces that I use whether it's
leather or own or animal parts or having
fabrics laser-cut or made that it's done
in a way that's sustainable or at least
low impact to environmental standards
just because that's I think the only
real way for fashion to go forward like
the animals already past and then in
general yeah I mean nothing nothing that
I use there were no animals harmed
we need to make this product generally
their secondary use products or the
animal died naturally and the bones or
the the pieces that I use were harvested
usually for taxidermy or for school's
things like that I get a lot of things
through a company called Paxton gate
yeah and they do a lot of things for
taxidermy and and stuff especially when
I'm using things like you know teeth
their bones our horn you didn't seedpods
things like that yeah and okay so before
we continue going into the nuance on all
of this which I'm really excited to
unpack with you tell us about how you
got here because you're born in New York
yes I was born on Long Island and grew
up there and then moved to the city when
I was about 14 or 15 not completely on
my own and not completely not on my own
and enjoyed New York for a few years and
then went to school went to school at
Cooper Union and had a great time there
what for painting I was a painter my my
parents are both artists in their own
way my father as a painter so they
always assumed that would be the path I
would take and I still do a lot of
painting and what I use I use an
airbrush quite a lot I want to use and
what I make I use a lot of hand painting
skills when I want to get a patina or a
shading or I don't think so they
certainly use it in that way and right
now outside of fashion I'm working on
our Commission right now of a painting
of prints of all things for somebody so
yeah I still I still use it but this
came about
I'd always sewn I'd always made things
and costumes when I was a kid my mother
had a sewing machine and and basically
said if you want to learn how to make
all these things that you want that's
great we'll get you so much you can make
it yourself oh oh I did well first
things I ever made there's a old David
Bowie movie called labyrinth
and he wore a leather jacket in it and I
wanted that leather jacket because I'm
David Bowie so I made my own version
attic crap I got it thrift stores and
and kind of picked it up that way
so it always made things and I had a lot
of friends who were in nightclubs and in
and you know when I was living in New
York I was sort of a little bit of a
club kid so I definitely made my own
things and and then when I moved here I
sort of focused more on the painting
aspect and then a friend of mine Emily
Paine who is a remarkably good fashion
designer on her own right and she was
invited with her brand at the time
leather tongue she showed a New York
Fashion Week at 2016 mm-hm and Emily
knew that I liked to sculpture because
in my paintings I use a lot of
three-dimensional things I don't just
paint straight out a lot of it is built
out and sculptural and so it there's a
3d aspect to smell my painting it's it's
a cross between sculpture and painting
and she had asked me if I wanted to make
some masks for her show the idea being
that a lot of her clothing is
androgynous it's sort of asexual and so
the masks were way of obscuring the
models faces so you weren't necessarily
drawn to the gender one way or another
and just about the clothing interest
line the design of them came from a idea
of punk to a certain degree so there is
a little bit of tribalism and and soft
painting and some of the prints that
Emily used and so we went with the idea
of well there's a bit of an Afrikaans
feel to some of it what would kids in
Africa who don't add me we access the
same sort of materials that we have here
punk riot punk rock wise go for mm-hmm
and so gravitated towards using things
that were natural I said to you from far
away this will look like a mohawk of you
know huge spikes then to get closer and
you see that it's all porcupine quills
and thinks things you would have
naturally found from the land or so
that's where that idea stemmed from
and then the masks went on the runway
and people seem to really like him I
sold half of what I produced that first
round whoa it was great yeah so
definitely made me feel like people
liked what I was doing
yes so so holy cow all right so I guess
one of the first things that you said
that I thought was really interesting
was this was this the the ability to use
a mask to sort of make it so that the
people that are observing the person
that is wearing whatever they are
wearing to be to make it androgynous or
asexual so that it is so they're focused
more on the clothing or the fashion
rather than the gender of the person
there's that aspect too but also just
masks in general have been around for
forever and in every culture they have
their own version whether it's a kabuki
mask or you know massive would have worn
in the Renaissance to go to you know a
big ball at a palace masks are a way for
people to very quickly change their
persona yeah without having to do much
and by having that barrier between
yourself and someone else I think it
gives people a bit of a license to be a
little a little outside of their comfort
zone and not take full responsibility
for it because you've already put on
this second layer so there's that to it
also but I think you know whether it's a
mask or t-shirt what we wear as people
dictates a lot of what we want to
present to the rest of the world about
what our interests are our values are or
even what our hierarchy is certainly
with the kind of stuff that I create
there's an aspect of don't [ __ ] with me
you know yeah that aspect I mean for
anybody who would wear something of mine
you're obviously in a Wallflower so I
think that's my aesthetic yeah I mean
you take a look at some of your you know
your Instagram account is linked in the
in the bio below and
when you look through some of this this
content it's it's cool that you can
actually see people that are rocking the
same sort of idea that you're talking
about right here like in this photo this
is your friend I'm Vanessa Getty this is
Vanessa she's in the center when and
needs a crown that she's wearing on that
and she's a big supporter of she's she's
a big supporter of the Arts in general
yes she really likes to make sure that
people that she's had a good experience
with are represented and she always
makes sure that people know whoever it
is created but she's wearing gets credit
for it and she's a lovely person too so
and and here you you know you mentioned
like again you made this yeah if you go
to the Instagram account click on it and
go to the next picture you actually see
that the crown itself Wow so that's what
it would it end up being yeah and look
at that look and that's so cool that
it's so intricate they did really a lot
of engineering goes into something like
that so absolutely now now I want to
stay on something that you said because
I can't let it escape do you have these
you know you have this you know what
these women are wearing here right they
are covering like half of their half of
the face when you're wearing these masks
and even when you you know when you pull
up an image like this as well when you
when you're covering half of your face
or when you're covering your eyes the
area around your eyes the other part has
to sort of take up that slack to be able
to convey to people and you've been you
were talking about it in a way that was
expressing to us especially to me right
now I didn't really think about it to
the extent at which you just taught me
about it which was that for hundreds of
years now
we've been we've been wearing things the
face is kind of a it's like the most
it's the way that someone knows you the
most is through you a most common social
barometer
an initial barometer I mean it is you
know you can tell a lot from someone
whether or not they make direct eye
contact with you or if they're
constantly darting all over yeah and
then in the same way by looking at
someone's mouth whether you can see it
or not
you know without a mask someone gets
nervous and their lips will start to
quiver or you know they'll lick their
lips the whole time being able to cover
that up to a certain degree allows you
to have a bit more control of what you
want to present to someone so there's a
reason of that there's a reason why
indigenous people would put on masks
before they would have a huge ceremony
or or whether it was for you know a
tribal Rite or for a wedding those they
allowed them to up the ante for their
emotional state I think to a certain
degree and take it to another level but
without that armor which is really what
it is it's hard for people to get to
that point if they're not someone who's
naturally outgoing that's so interesting
that you know you know it's a weird
thing to say but I hear more times than
not when people have tried on one of my
masks that they feel like it allows them
to be a lot more free which is funny
when you're putting something on your
face and taking away some of your
natural ability to a moat but I think it
also allows you to tap into a part of
yourself that maybe you're not naturally
inclined to this is this is cool you you
you you know just before you get here
the you use a friend Jared by the way
he's awesome and he fixes motorcycles
and a pretty cool guy hey Jerry shout
out to shout outs of friends that are
supporting artists he helped me move
into my entire studio there's like came
in and helped me build stuff and he's a
pretty awesome guy so uh I know your
studio is so cool it's in the same
building as we're in which is you know
it's a it's a reason why we met and I'm
really happy I'm really happy that that
we did now okay you use the word social
barometer I think that's so interesting
and so you're you're talking and and
these the idea of masks or or or
covering parts of this major social
barometer to more enable us to feel
more free it's in some ways master are
one of the things that I use for my
aesthetic but it's not just that it's
it's any piece of clothing that you use
can be is almost always a social
barometer if a guy decides he wants to
wear a t-shirt and the sleeves are cut
off because he want to show off his
muscles that's a social barometer saying
I am showing you a part of me that I
consider to be dominant and that will
make me feel like I'm in charge and
masculine or conveying a certain stance
or if a woman decides that she wants to
either be buttoned up to here or that
she wants to be less buttoned up to have
some cleavage showing or have some
muscles right
that is a way of saying this is what I'm
comfortable with presenting and this
part I'm not comfortable presenting so
it's a schematic like wow you're you
have your tats you know you're right
that's on your arms and you know you're
wearing a short sleeve so people can see
right but if I were say going to church
which likely perhaps perhaps I wouldn't
do that although in my mind I probably
would do it I'd probably wear that you
know the cutoff t-shirt to show off more
of them I imagine our Lance Victor Moore
and some other gold short shorts are
that's going to church I'd like have a
de you'd be surprised that I have
nothing against Church I have a lot
against say organized religion Church
different thing yeah totally and so it'd
be funny to see like a group of 12
people walking into church wearing your
mask the Church of Lance Victor Moore
okay so that was so fascinating the so
she imagined my Eucharist that would be
very interesting I I love I love how
much you know you this this is actually
the one that's right here that is you
have something mask and so yeah you can
and okay so now here would be a good
segue to go into this you were talking
about another thing that you were
mentioning at the very beginning was
you're mentioning the the amount of
nature that is evident as well you were
saying that if you were in in Africa and
you were making masks you know you'd
probably be making it with some sort of
these of these bullies maybe
with the you know the fabric part here
but yeah yeah yeah and then here what
were these called this this was an
Australian saw on this mask yeah so this
mask so there's actually a lot of
reclaimed pieces in this the skin as a
python skin and it's actually from the
60s I bought it this is Python skin
right yeah the skin itself is from the
60s yeah I've had it forever I bought it
whoa I'm a little online auction so and
again it was rolled up in this lady's
attic or something that she went through
it and she put all this stuff and she's
like I remember when my mom went to
Zanzibar or something and she bought all
these skins and I want to get rid of
them so I bought one so yeah damn and
then these pieces here are actually
called a devil's claw they believe if
I'm correct they're from Australia they
are actually seed pod and they grow in a
tree and it's a barb it's so that the
tree can protect itself you can probably
look up one if you Devils devil's claw
right there's one right there
yeah these guys here yeah okay oh those
guys yeah yeah they look like naturally
incredible claw fruits yeah but it's
it's a seed pod on the inside I mean I
guess it's probably a nut or something
but the inside is hollow
but these parts here are she incredibly
strong they're really flexible and what
I understand is that people indigenous
people actually will break them off and
use them either for earrings or use them
to even hang garments of clothing the
same way that we would use a clothing
old clothing line hook so they'll use
these and hang them all over trees to
clothe you'll wash their garments or to
hang skins in that way
so and then the inside is lined in and
just regular leather skins
now I mean the way that you break this
down is just so interesting because you
this is not a you know this takes this
is why there's a lot of Engineers it's
like going on in it is this something
multi like is this like a 40-hour
Oh easily this I mean something like
that the engineering part is the hardest
because I have to decide what what I
wanted to look like and how I want it to
extend out and then how to get it there
and still keep it light
I keep it breathable and more
importantly make sure that things aren't
going to start to slope on it so if you
look on the inside of it let's look on
the inside on the inside first off
you'll be able to see that it's
incredibly light so that's one of the
things that people usually are not
prepared for what my master like oh yeah
it's like I what are you at it's like
it's just one pound
oh it's less than a pound it's like half
of yeah that's less than one pound
yeah it's probably about yeah twelve
ounces 12 ounces yeah it's very very
light yeah no it's true and all the
pieces on it also are detachable because
obviously if I'm sending it to someone
in Japan I can't send it like this so
these pieces the front piece they all
come off and they can be read reput on
wherever you go and show us how easy it
is to take off the pieces if you want to
turn it to like Japan or something I'm
not sure I even need a I don't think I
even need a just like that look at that
you've got to just screw right in and
screw right out like that huh so Wow
look how easy though there's a screw
there see also hold that you want to
don't want to lose him yeah Wow but that
way yes completely and this is the whole
thing here was you know it's it's it's
drilled and there's a pin that goes
inside of it yep and yes why does it
scoot back on and easy breezy but then
there's a metal rod on the inside that
actually holds all the weight of these
and keeps them in place so there's a lot
of under structure inside of this
there's two layers there's an inside
layer of leather on the outside and the
inside has a wire mesh so the entire
mask is also flexible and can be shaped
to people's faces and be comfortable so
you can bend it so it fits your drawing
better or if it's around your nose
better all these things you did good
yeah actually and it's interesting that
it pretty much screws right back into
the side and then they you can see it
you can kind of twist them so that you
make sure
stays nice and then the insight may be
screwed them but yeah but in general I
try and make it easy for people because
good design is usually simple design
good design is usually simple you know I
mean not that something incredibly
complex isn't good design but what I
have found is people don't want to have
to beat you thinking other way that way
there you go that goes on the cookies
gotta go in the bridges yeah just like
that do you want me to clip it on you so
generally it's worn higher on the head
and they're adjustable also you know I
have a bigger head there well that's why
there's elastic yeah interesting
there you go how's that feel wow this is
pretty cool because there's just there's
something really interesting about
having these you know be right in your
sight of vision but they don't obscure
to me they don't mean here you know I
mean I think one of the things is you
have to be in the mindset for it this is
something where this makes me like this
makes me want to like move around and
get excited and like go and show the
world like look at look at what I'm
wearing right now because it's so it's
beautiful it's so it's so different you
know it's not your conventional it's not
your conventional I'm wearing a just
like a you know a t-shirt and pants
right yeah I mean I think it's it's like
anything it's within context this is not
something you're probably gonna wear
every day but what I've what I have
found is a question I was across the
board is that people who've purchased my
masks or any of what I create they tend
to wear it to one particular function
they have in mind I had a couple last
year a friend of mine who runs a blog
called style Eddy she has she purchases
a mask for herself and for her husband a
matching set and they wore it to this
big black and white soiree
they both he wore a tux and she wore
Jevon she dress yeah and then after they
wore them they hung them on their wall
as an art piece and now exactly it
becomes this sort of art piece for this
piece that they could talk to about
people and what is that over you know
it's it's it's cool in that way you know
another thing that I really like about
this usually one high in the head higher
on the head yep think of it like a
facelift it's got to have a little bit
of pull going up yeah that exists there
you go so now another thing that I
notice about this is that you have these
holes here oh yeah they said not to make
it breathable for people yeah and it's
actually quite you know it's quite
breathable in that sense well and that's
also one of the earlier masts and I made
some of the ones that I made further on
I tried to incorporate eat it more
ease of where the one behind you if you
look at it
yes copper one if you take a look at the
inside of that one it's actually it's a
hand hold leather so the leather that
had been burned out on it but the entire
under structure of it is actually a fine
wire mash that's copper so that one is
an incredible amount of breathability
and that one yeah because oh yeah yeah
and that one is four ounces for ounces
the entire piece of forums readily light
oh my gosh this is all light yeah that's
something that you can you can
completely breathe in and look at look
at that yeah look at how house how
transparent it is because it's a copper
mesh that's a copper mesh and then it's
burnt and leather you said on the
outside it's hand hand rolled leather so
the inside of it has got holes that have
been meaning to the holes and then I
went in and rolled it so it would give
it a texture oh that's so cool yeah you
know I wanted to say this about gonna
loosen it a little bit cuz you have a
big head I have a big head so right here
it says a little knotch and then you
just pull that yeah I'd say that's what
I can fit you better okay
the something else that I wanted to
mention about these I mean holy cow this
one's so light yes but you're not gonna
break it I promise this one so this
one's so breathable yeah so I definitely
figured out as I've gotten how do I get
a cool look but that's very easy to work
with
oh this feels do that one actually looks
really out of the two of them I actually
like that one on you better cuz I feel
like it's a little to me it's a little
slicker for you yeah this one I can see
you wearing that with a leather jacket
or something and going to the right club
and being the vampire guy in the corner
sticking out those are porcupine quills
these are porcupine yeah those are
porcupine quills that are projecting
from it let's take a look at them so how
does so now opening another screw on
like men's grew off
and okay so now you know you know here's
here's a couple questions
you know this requires a lot of you know
a sourcing of different materials a lot
of designing this so that it like you
said there's a it's a multi hour process
of even you know of engineering and
piecing these things together look at I
mean look at the intricacies here I'll
show you the inside
you know there's look at you know look
at how many of there you know there's
there's really something ribbons
rivets and and there's piecing on it and
again what the that kind of a this was
actually a relatively easy piece to make
but if you look at say something like
the piece by your knee the woman that is
actually a it's a cast from a cat's
spine that one is with a relatively
complicated piece to make because of the
engineering that went into it and also
to a certain degree is articulated not a
lot that has a little bit of
articulation so this lot of the cast of
a cat's part of ah yes part of and then
part of it was 3d printed and part of it
was hand sculpted so it's a combination
of three things
really and so I originally designed this
on my computer with Photoshop to sort of
create the shape that was what I wanted
from the side view which was the sill
you know that the the profile yeah and
then getting it to that point and so I
had purchased a portion of a cat spine
and cast it and one resin and then
repeated that casting and then sculpted
parts of it that I had wanted around the
edges to create a better shape and then
the piece behind it here which is this
this notched piece that was actually
done on
a 3d printer and then covered so it's
got different aspects but I didn't know
where to start on this piece they knew
that I wanted something that had a bit
of a skeletal feel to it of everyone
calls us the face hugger so I've come to
be okay with that however it was not
inspired by Gieger but I look eager this
you know coming up with these types of
designs is so interesting because who is
like I'm gonna put this Australian
Devils what was called the devil's claw
claw on my face or I want to put a cat
spine going from my you know mouth and
it looks like ribs right here which is
like the RZA which was definitely the
the aesthetic part of exactly and I'd
look at the way that the tail curves are
the back of the spine this is definitely
all about the the side profile you know
that was was that what this was created
for was for a photo shoot again with my
friend Emily pain from one of her
dresses and the model wore this but it
was it was mostly about trying to get
this very sleek curvature from the side
profile so I didn't worry so much about
how it looked from the front as much as
from the side and I wanted a different
shape than what I had been used to doing
which was the sort of all-over face
pieces and this one actually has two
straps there's one is two straps because
I wanted to make sure that the the
center piece stayed in place right and
didn't sort of flop around too much I
don't have them on it right now but if
you look on the inside in here there's
actually two areas where there are screw
holes that are embedded because at one
point it actually had two flanges that
came out this way too and came back Wow
but we decided to discard them because
we liked this more slick but those
pieces are still there as residuals of
their original design
cally this is so so so interesting but
yeah so a piece like that is that's for
me my favorite way of using a computer
or using you know three-dimensional
design what I have seen as a unfortunate
aspect of
they're of the way that 3d design and 3d
printing has been used in fashion and
and in a lot of different artistic
mediums is that it's used across the
board to convey something and I think it
takes a little bit of the natural human
element out of it I feel like a lot of
the best things that I've done with any
of my work is the mistakes and a
computer and a lot of senses helps take
away a lot of the burden of creating a
mistake especially when it comes to
things like symmetry measure twice cut
once right measure create but also I
feel like especially with design or
anything creative it's those mistakes
that can make something look more
beautiful it gives it a sense of being
touched by a human hand and so I have no
interest in making say a fully realized
piece of clothing or a mask that was
done completely on a computer because
then for me I feel like it doesn't
really what part of it that I have was
involved with I may have had the initial
idea but there has to be some sort of
human element for it to be interesting
to me so I think that hybrid between
using a printed piece or a laser cut
piece or something that was cut on a on
a water jet cutter those are great
things to incorporate into something
that I did by hand
yeah and helps elevate both of those
elements more than if they were just by
themself which can feel a little cold
you're actually adding quite a bit of
technology into the mix yeah technology
look at NOAA tina.bill engineering
that's Michael by the way the one I
designed that master you're funny enough
the little dot in the middle of his
mouth if you see yep that was one of the
few things he requested because he's a
DJ so we ended up putting a hole there
so he could have a straw so he could
drink so he could drink things so that's
actually big enough for him to put a
metal straw that
spotty funny yeah that's our you were
saying I'm saying that it's so cool that
you have so many of these design and
engineering principles and tools like
Photoshop you were teaching us about the
ability to be able to make something
like like a like the 3d for right so I
mean well patterning is relatively very
old the old school I mean it since we've
had clothing we've had patterns for it
even it was just a buckskin wrapped
around us but everybody wore that same
buckskin to say I was part of this
particular tribe there was a
standard-bearer this is what that should
be in that you you know dictates you
were part of this group or you're part
of that group when actual patterning
became a really big thing where it was
not just about function but it was also
about fashion you know you're looking at
probably about the 1400s something like
that where people started to create
clothing not as a functional device of I
need to be covered but I want to show my
status in a real way so I'm gonna create
a corset or I'm going to have very
particular colors that only Royals can
wear things like that but the patterning
of it became interesting because it was
the first time where people went out of
their way to change the shape of the
human body on purpose so you see men
wearing large pantaloons to create a
silhouette for them that gave them
larger legs and a tinier waist to
emphasize below the waist there's a
reason why that silhouette was created
it was to draw the eyes down some men
could basically say look at my codpiece
that was that that beginning of that and
same thing for women it was about
pulling in the ways to create a corset
and by doing that you're inevitably
because it's there's only so much you
can do with matter matter has to going
away one way or another you're making
one area smaller you're never really
gonna make the other parts larger so the
waist becomes smaller and the bosom and
that and the the butt become bigger and
those all add to that aesthetic return
create no one really did that before
that time because it was not
paramount to our survival yeah but we
got to a point where we didn't have to
necessarily worry about food as much
because we had farming we didn't have to
worry about where we were living cuz
everyone had a home whether it was a
Shack or palace and so people could
focus on those things a little bit more
as we got into the Industrial Age it it
jumped up a notch ten times more when we
could not only cut out a pattern of
something that we liked for a shirt but
have 400 of them cut for us in a day
because of an automated machine yeah
that changed everything for everyone who
worked in that industry and so in a
strange way because it was so easy to
create a very consistent product over
and over and over again inevitably that
pendulum swings back and people want
something more unique that's one of a
kind because they know if I like this
pair of jeans from Levi's I can buy as
many of that pair of jeans as I want and
it's always gonna be the same thing it's
gonna have the exact same fit the same
sheen everything's going to be exact
where if you say buy something that's
bespoke by one particular person who
makes only four pairs of jeans a week
because they make it all by hand yeah
you have that ability to say what I'm
wearing is unique and special and so I
feel like there's we're going back in a
smaller way to that design to the
artisanal bespoke well sure in a sense a
fast fashion which is what we we call it
in the industry is is absolutely here to
stay
fashion is the big piles of clothing at
costs H&M kind of stuff where it's it's
quick to produce it's very cheap and it
doesn't last very long but it doesn't
need to last very long because you're
only wearing it for a season if that or
until the next trend hits yeah and and
that's it's fine for what it is I think
for a lot of people it's what they can
afford and especially for younger people
but I'm lucky enough to be able to
produce some of the stuff that I enjoy
producing and have a small group of
people who are
very into it allow me to continue
facilitating that and that allows me to
be one of those people that makes those
bespoke pieces you can still afford a
studio here in San Francisco Joe which
very few of my friends who are in design
or art can do right now because it's so
expensive so yeah I think having that
niche but it's also quality control I
mean anybody can you know throw paint
out of canvas and call it a painting I
think there's a certain sense of
understanding technique that is what
elevates any creative endeavor whether
it's totally Photoshop and knowing how
to use it as a tool or knowing how to
use a sewing machine I love the way that
you talk about it in evolutionary terms
that once we had more food and shelter
that was secure for us that we were able
to focus more on some of these like
aesthetics of the way that we present
ourselves to the world and then
furthermore once we got into like the
Industrial Revolution age it went a lot
from the similar to the the printing
press you had a write a Bible by hand or
a book by hand then you could just know
it was a very special thing to have that
Bible yeah
when everyone can have a Bible it did
two things it leveled the playing field
because now everyone has the same
information yeah and though doesn't have
to go to a secondary person to
disseminate that information to them you
don't have to go to your priest and ask
them what does the Bible say about
so-and-so and he regurgitates that to
you you know have your own copy you can
look it up for yourself what that also
does unfortunately and this is with
whether it's clothing or with anything
it allows people who perhaps don't have
the full knowledge of what it is they
now have in their hand to make their own
interpretation without doing the
homework first and so when it came to
things like clothing anybody can go out
there and produce you know they're a
line of jeans if they wanted to but the
quality control necessarily wasn't great
because they weren't even involved in it
they would send it overseas and have it
done so-and-so and they'd have a thing
and they didn't care if it lasted long
or not because in a season
it's gonna be gone anyway and I move on
to the next thing one of the things
about me being able to do it here is
that I I'm responsible good or bad for
what I produce to someone and so I have
to make sure that it's it's what I want
it to present I'm I'm I want to also
showcase all of this other there's so
much more to showcase and right so the
mask for the thing that started but
really my cuffs and clothing and things
are the things that really would be the
second one in these are called cuffs and
clothing yep first one for you because
I'm big wrists there you go so and we so
that'll be on my that's a piece that I
actually produced unless I sell it
beforehand it's gonna go on my my first
show which is next year services it was
dubiously called the spider cuff it kind
of looks like a spider yeah and there's
a you know when I first I think I was
like the first thing you ever tried on
with my when I first met you in like in
the round may you know here's that
here's you here's that here's that
picture you know and I I do really like
this piece it's it's it reminds me a lot
of kind of like a Star Trek II in future
I
I really like that about it it also says
very arachnid as well it's very it is
yeah so kind of like Sputnik a little it
looks like Sputnik a little yeah and you
have a bunch of different designs like
this and like sharp things yeah yeah
Thank You Ronnie so so let's you know
you you know you you started us off into
the direction of talking about so yeah
so talk about things that are that are
the masks is what God should go away but
there's old half of your mass lots of
more of it not been sold half on your
first like exhibit which was huge great
and then that like you said that was
really inspirational for you to continue
making well it made me feel like I was
able to do it and not do it in a
hackneyed kind of way you know I didn't
want it to be
a craft project if I was going to do it
just like my paintings I wanted it to be
an elevated version of it there are not
you know I have a very small list of
people who are influences in my life as
far as fashion goes because it's not
what I went to school for but I
definitely did my research and found
people inspired me and uses and then
when I would find those inspirations it
wasn't just about okay well I like the
way that looks but it was more well how
did that person go about producing that
what was how do I think that they got
from point A to point C and then I would
do a lot of trial and error you know I
have a drawer downstairs order of things
that were good ideas but not not viable
you know to get to a point of say
something like this so this was actually
cutting on the metal piece of this was
cut on a wow this is a real water water
jet yeah it's just a water jet and I
wanted to create something that sort of
held its shape was you can bend it very
flexible and would fit anybody and so
yeah so exactly just like that so so
that was a cool piece but that was
totally designed in CAD and like what is
the shape I want and then we laid up and
then we took the CAD file flattened it
out and then I had that cut on a lathe
yeah that tack rate and this is so light
what is it it's aluminum this is
aluminum it's aluminum and then it's
been hand pounded so the shape which is
what you get right so you get that nice
textural texture makes it a medieval
right a medieval kind of veiny a little
baby yeah yeah light as a feather very
very strong flexible but what's nice
about it is it's one of those pieces
that anybody can wear you to suggest it
quickly it can fit a man a woman which
with accessories is not usually the case
it's usually you have to have a lot of
bubbles and a lot of look at that just
we go puke yep boom
I love that piece it's such a haven't
eaten it yet so do you name all your
pieces for myself I do just so I have an
idea of what it what it was and so if
people want to reference it or
or look it up they can but I also feel
like some of them just have a natural
tendency to to need to be named like
these guys here this is one of the first
things I produced eight of these and
this is the last one that I have Misha
so this was cut on a laser cutter and
then the inside is actually a wireframe
and it was named by my client Kim who I
adore as the dirty Lily for obvious
reasons right Wow yeah boy you know
boring oh is that most of you it's not
necessarily literal interpretation but
there's a there's a there's a soft
reference there so that's a beautiful
soft ref right soft reference it's a
lovely soft reference where does this is
just a necklace it's a necklace thing oh
wow but yeah no it's a necklace but that
whole pattern for the flower itself is
cut on a laser cutter there's a front in
the back and then there's a metal mesh
inside and that the entire thing is sewn
there you go and so that's that piece
but again it's very flexible so if you
were to say squish it or bend it it just
bends right back into its own shapes and
stuff and it's silver and right you just
bend it back and you're all good to go
it's really interesting yeah well it's
it's a cool but it's funny because it
was one of those things right I made it
and I liked it and I did a version in
golden deer diversion and silver and I'd
I couldn't keep him in so I can keep him
in they were I mean I believe I've made
eight of them so far and this is the
last one so something that was great
because I was like well I can't never
gonna get it
to be the same so being able to cut it
out and the laser cutter was great
because I was able to go quickly but
then someone gets it by hand and do you
consider making eight or sixteen more of
those ever well I decided if I'm gonna
do what I'm gonna have them ready to go
and then I don't have to worry about it
it would this is probably one of the few
things I've ever done in a real
production sense there's a photo of them
up here I think at least four of them so
you can see the the gold ones and all
that with the red
oh yeah so I made a foreign gold for and
silver and that was them they had a
different courting at the time actually
ended up changing it this this last one
I ended up putting a chain on but they
had a lot of different courting at the
time but that's one of the few things
I've ever done as a real production most
of what I do is I'll make one or two and
then I'll decide whether or not I'm
gonna do more based on whether it's a
success and then so and then how do you
decide whether or not to make more of
those you know if I get a request or if
it seems like they flew off the shelf
low of the shelf I mean one of the
things that have sold really well for me
on here are those little fur cuffs right
here yeah yeah I saw earlier so the
third one of that again it's a it's a
laser cut piece on the center Wow
and then the rest is its pony skin and
Kashmir and Kashmir and then it's a just
buckles on yeah but I made one of those
sold I mean another one sold so this is
the third one
but you know having a pattern for that
is certainly helpful yeah you got it
say that's a cool piece it is like that
interesting but yeah then there's things
like the master really those are
obviously gonna be one off because the
amount of time it takes to make and if
someone buy something like one of those
months they probably want to be the only
one that has it now I've made things
that are similar because people you know
say oh if you have any more of that you
say you don't so you make another one
but I don't I get bored pretty quickly
you want a key so the idea new things so
so if you made like 16 of those it would
be kind of like yeah I'm not gonna
probably make any more this is the last
one so anybody wants it you know move on
to other things
because for myself most people go
purchase through your deal
I have a very lovely clientele here in
the city of of regular clients who are
always purchasing things yeah and so
I've been lucky in that way mostly
though people will message me and say
hey a friend of mine was wearing
such-and-such and do you have it anymore
and I'll either say yes or no but I can
create one for you if you'd like and
entry she come to my studio and I have
people come over a lot and pick what
they like what they like people to be
involved so they can another laser cut
leather on the back of that is actually
really an interesting material it's from
the 30s it's real silver thread so that
the metallic part yep so it's from the
30s you actually have to polish it
because it's a real silver threading so
quick a quick question this is totally
silver threading it's very interesting
now quick a quick question is you said
that you know you get bored easily
because you want to make new things and
you want to and people want to be the
only person that in the world that has
it and that's part of having a niche
which is great as me being able to say
if you're certain agreed there is only
one of these and so if you want you want
it come get it but it's like anything if
you go to a car showroom usually the car
you see on the floor is not the one you
end up buying
say I like that car but can I have
that in red yeah yeah a lot of times
I'll have people say I really like this
but I'd love you to make me one in gold
so I will go well I can make you
something similar I have it you know I
have this and this and this and let's
say it out and work with it and it
becomes a collaborative thing yeah which
is what's cool about it I like the
collaboration aspect of it I like being
able to create something for someone
that has an idea in their head but they
don't really have the ability to make it
themselves and you know I end up
becoming that conduit yeah that gets do
you say this is how we can create that
that piece you want whether it's you
know a cool piece of jewelry or a mask
or you know as you see here what I'm
getting started with which is my first
real fashion show so so now to know tell
us where where is your time being
allocated between masks BRE what are you
look ups cuffs cuffs masks and dresses
well at the moment the cuffs and the
masks have paid for me to be able to
have the ability to make the dresses
gotcha
so I'm starting to really finish up a
lot of the things that have that are
half finished in my studio for the
accessories and begin the year I'm gonna
focus solely on my show which I'm
planning to have around this time next
year
a show of dresses yeah of dresses while
people are also wearing not necessarily
maybe not okay no I haven't I have a bit
of an idea and the masks are I've been
wonderful and I always want to sort of
pay tribute to it and I may have one or
two on my show but I want to be able to
move past that as not being a one-trick
pony totally so I'm gonna incorporate a
lot of the things that I've learned babe
by using engineering and design and and
that along with being able to create
something on a larger scale which I like
with more right more people will wear
right you're also just gonna be able to
have somebody feel they can get more use
out of it you know it's something that
you you're able to to create in a larger
a larger scale
they don't wear it once and put it on
the wall right now Lance give us a quick
idea
are we talking you know these are like a
couple
hundred dollars and these are a couple
thousand dollars I feel like I'm on an
infomercial they range generally my cuff
serve between 200 and 400 dollars
depending what goes into them yep the
masks range between eight and twelve
hundred dollars okay and again it
depends on on what went into it that's
not to say that that's a hard case
scenario I had a mask that's on here
which is all porcupine quills and
crystal which was the finale piece of
our New York Show and that was over
$2,000 and that's old she's a lovely
lady who's up for there down probably
yeah if you go down to there's a model
wearing a bunch of my masks I keep going
keep going you'll get to the whole area
where they're all wearing the masks
there you go
there she is so that one there oh whoa
so that piece was the finale piece for
Emily's in my show in New York and that
piece so it was sera ski crystal and
chrome and like 48 Wow individual
porcupine quills and each one was set
individually with a little screw so they
could all be taken off and reassembled
yeah so that piece sold this last
Halloween which was great and the lady
who bought it was lovely I don't I don't
want to say her name because I don't
want to embarrass her but she is a
cancer survivor Wow
and she was having a party and she had
shaved her head and she didn't have any
hair at the time and she said I thought
this was in a window you know window
display and she said I saw it in the
window and I came back to it three weeks
later and I really really want it
because I want to be able to wear
something that's gonna make me feel
really confident because right now I'm
not feeling super-confident yeah and so
she ended up purchasing it and I ended
up adjusting it a little bit for her
because it's all metal and she said she
had a great time she sent me a picture
of her wearing it and it was one of the
cooler experiences with it yeah cuz when
I had made it I figured that piece of
anybody ever bought it was going to be
some rich kid who can afford it and wear
it once and it's probably gonna get
destroyed and so I had made my peace
with the fact that you know probably
give me somebody who isn't gonna
appreciate it the I'll cash the check
then I'll never see it again and in fact
that it went to somebody who used it for
a special occasion yes and then it has
it on her on her mantle as something
that she can put on and sort of feel her
about it after having fought cancer like
that was kind of cool to me and then you
know on are you absolutely on that's it
that there's no better thing a designer
can get them to get someone like that
he's really genuinely moved by something
that you create not just like I think
it's pretty I'd like to have it but this
piece really moves me I want to have it
to me that's awesome that's awesome yeah
now he okay now you're transitioning to
the show and see focusing a lot more of
your time on next show I am I was really
lucky client of mine who's also a friend
Kim who is Kim's been a client of mine
probably from the very beginning one of
the biggest supporters of mine she
worked in finance and she and I talked
and and and stuff and I told her you
know I really want haven't my first show
they don't know how to go about it and I
don't know how to raise funds for it and
I also I'm a little nervous of what if
it's a big failure and I said I don't
want to go into debt over it you know I
live I'm not a rich person and so her
idea was she said we'll do what they
would do in any industry and you need to
find someone to become a patron so the
the business model we came up with very
quickly was if I tapped enough people to
basically sponsor a dress before it was
produced I was able to raise capital
beforehand and what you're doing is
purchasing a dress sight unseen and once
it's produced it's now yours but you're
buying at a year in advance I'm so buddy
being able to do that I was able to have
a little bit of capital get all the
materials and you're like what you've
seen down there
yeah and start focusing on the show but
the genius aspect of it is is when the
show comes out I'll be able to say
before it ever hit the runway that ten
of the pieces sold yeah which is great
for PR exec
so good idea Kim Thanks so I'm focusing
on that now because I want to have my
show probably around this time next year
Lance we are so excited to be helped out
with the show next year I would love to
help out well I'm gonna need somebody to
do some videography for it or get the
word out we'll do videography we would
love to do that this is some this is I'd
love for you guys to be there this is
the future of fashion you you're very
sustainable you're very you know you're
very focused on technology on all the
different aspects that you can plug to
make this sustainable as well with tech
and also just the you know the sheer
amount of just ascent Rissa t it's just
so you know it's there's so many things
that are that we barely barely touched
on in the in fashion and that are coming
up
things like nanotechnology that people
are going to be incorporating sooner
than you think into clothing with you
know things that the idea of being able
to have clothing that built into it have
microbe eating abilities so you don't
have to change your shirt every day
because you are literally cleaning it as
you wear it because that technology is
being is being developed or developed
right now in Japan or things like
natural leathers quote-unquote that are
a lot healthier for the environment
that's a what we call vegan leather now
which is really just vinyl not very good
for the environment it creates a whole
different cadre of problems that aren't
much better for the world than emissions
from a cow farm
it's mycelium is right mycelium is a but
if you use something say a leather
that's created from bacteria which is a
screening of sugar and then that sugar
solidifies and it creates this this hard
substance that you can not only you know
cut and and color and do all these
things with but that leaves no natural
gases there's no extra runoff from it
because it colors itself naturally these
are all things that are being down the
pipeline that people are gonna be using
in the future and I'm excited to be able
to
that kind of stuff in what I do to be
able to literally take a mold of your
torso and grow a shirt around you that
has no seams and that fits you perfectly
and it's breathable and that is made
specifically for you and that can not
only draw out the heat from you when
you're feeling hot we can also insulate
you when you're getting cold those are
all things that are literally being
produced right now and it's very
small-scale and in development but as it
progresses in it you know the way that
we have things go from point A to point
C nowadays is remarkably fast because we
have that ability to do rapid
prototyping you're going to see these
things on the market within the next
three to five years easily and readily
available to anybody and as people latch
on to it the price point will come down
like any new technology it's so it
starts high but it will come back down
and I think when people see that ability
to really be involved in what they wear
and not just buy it off the rack they'll
be able to say this is something that I
had a hand in yeah people will feel
invested in the technology in and of
itself I think that that's important
even in the smallest way when I have
someone come in and they pick the the
leather that they light in you they they
become invested in the thing that
they're there procuring yeah because
that's not just I went and I picked a
nice you know belt from you know Dior
but I had involvement of this so I'm
more likely to take care of this piece
I'm more likely to not just throw it out
when I'm tired of and fill up a landfill
these are all things that that
contribute to because if someone feels
invested in whatever they're putting
their money into the more likely to take
care of it which also helps the
environment because you're less likely
to just chuck it when you're done like
it's not a H&M t-shirt exactly no you
were listing all these technologies that
are coming up and it was so cool you
know seeing you tearing about them and
in teaching us about how they're coming
into our world it's Lance it's so cool
seeing artists like you that are
designers a fashion that are able to
come into the world with success because
people have found their work to be
meaningful and wants to support them and
we love that on the show we love the
artists that are breaking through into
the world and this has been such a
pleasure sitting down with all thank you
for supporting the arts and having me on
I've been happy to to come up and show
you a little bit of what I work on but
more importantly it's it's cool that
hopefully this inspires other designers
younger people who are working on it to
know that it's easier to create
something quick and disposable but you
will have much more ability to feel
pride in what you do if you take the
time to not only suss out where you're
buying things from and how you're
procuring them but taking the time to
really get to know what you're working
with will make you appreciate and value
your own work which inevitably will make
other people value your work too that's
what Couture is all about so that's what
Couture is all about I love the way that
you're talking about the young audiences
and and putting in longer time
sustainable sourcing I think it's it's
an unfortunate trade off from the
remarkable ability that we have now to
be able to find and access knowledge at
a given second that's wonderful I think
being able to say I want this and I want
to know about this right now is amazing
the downside to that is people's
attention spans are are minuscule and so
you find a lot of designers in fashion
especially where their ability to think
about what they want is there but their
ability to actually create it is
absolutely not and same thing with
almost every other right so they don't
really care about the process they just
want to see the end result I have this
idea in my head and I want to see it so
I'm gonna go to the quickest route to
get to that thing if you actually know
how to create that dress from beginning
and how to cut a pattern where those
fabrics come from what goes into being
able to dye those fabrics and how
horrendous it can be on the environment
you're more likely to try and find
alternatives that will fit your
narrative
but still allow you to sleep at night
but also on the other aspect you will
learn through having to produce it on
your own
a real skillset that nobody can take
away from you it's easy if you have the
monetary cachet to be able to hire
someone else to do something for you and
produce your idea that's how 99% of all
fashion designers do it
they're the designer and someone else
creates it when I'm someone who not only
designs it but finds my materials and
creates them I am in control of that
whole system but I'm also responsible
for it which makes me accountable and
being accountable for your creativity
and what you put into the world is just
as important as having the idea to put
it into there yep
yes you have to be accountable yup yep
Lance what do you think the most
beautiful thing in the world what I
think the most beautiful thing in the
world is people being true to themselves
and not really caring what others think
I love it so much what a good answer
what a beautiful endeavor that you have
go and check out Lance's links below in
the bio also go and build the future go
manifest your destiny into the world
everyone go and be yourself your fullest
self and go and put that hard work in
and leave us your thoughts in the
comments below we'd love to hear from
you thanks everyone for tuning in and
for watching and greatly appreciate
thanks for on for producing and
directing much love to you and we will
see you soon everyone much love peace
[Applause]
[Music]
you